the ali stadium who felt the
passion for soccer again on the night of
september 22 when leon faced
aarón sanders the game was even
since both clubs had arrivals
although the first half ended
goalless a few minutes before the start of the
second  part
took the lead with a goal scored by
cristian roldan after 12 minutes
the lion's response would come to
tie the game in the 81st minute
a penalty taken by ángel mena would go up behind
emanuel gigliotti
took advantage of a rebound and scored the third
for the club  Mexican while in
extra minutes
Nicolás Benezet scores the second for Saunders
after a deflection of the defense close but
it was not enough León is champion of the
Lix Cap 2021 after beating Sanders 3-2
Natalia Lanzelotti reported for them in Spanish